dear Educators dear Learners their
citizens and Friends
we all have classmates colleagues or
family members with dyslexia
individuals who are intelligent and
talented
but who are often stigmatized and feel
shame
simply because they have a different way
of learning
according to the European dyslexia
Association
around 12 percent of the global
population has the condition
this means one in eight people in our
society
both have a disability and a gift
to see the world differently
for too long we have overlooked the
power of dyslexic thinking
and this must change
and this is why through Education and
Research the European Union is helping
to empower dyslexic individuals
in 2022 together with our member states
we adopted the so-called Pathways to
school Success
it includes best practices to make our
classrooms more inclusive
first of all through targeted And Timely
support
which requires early detection of
dyslexia
thanks to our Horizon Euro program
we're funding such projects like change
dyslexia which is making early diagnosis
possible and scalable
second we recommend equipping teachers
and parents with the skills and
resources they need to provide support
including through open online courses
thanks to our Erasmus Plus program
we have helped to develop the first
European course about learning disorders
and perhaps most importantly third
let us always be open to new ways of
learning and providing encouragement
to all Learners regardless of age
especially those with disabilities
and this is why I welcome any
international support or attention to
dyslexia
dyslexia is an obstacle we can overcome
together as a society
the European Union is at your side in
fact
just two weeks ago we registered a
European citizens initiative
on specific learning disabilities
including dyslexia
we will follow up with a European
response
to ensure that access to education
and success in life
is a right to all
thank you very much for your attention